it has been another violent week in the
West Bank six dead in six days three
Palestinians and three Israelis
last night a 17 year old boy Mohamed
Salim was shot and killed during clashes
with Israeli forces
hometown
as hundreds of Palestinians were at the
cemetery for his burial
um
[Music]
the IDF says that Muhammad Salim was
part of a group that first attacked
Israeli cars on a nearby Road and then
through Molotov cocktails at Israeli
Soldiers the Doctor Who treated him and
tried to save him told us that the
teenager was shot in the back
um
the division and anger has always been
there but it is now growing on both
sides 64 Palestinians have been killed
in clashes with Israeli forces this year
all of them inside the West Bank
Muhammad Saleem is the 13th child to
have been killed it's turning out to be
one of the most violent years in decades
Israel has defended its actions and says
that many of the Dead were militants who
were planning Terror attacks against
Israel the UN has criticized the killing
of children
there has been growing International
pressure for calm but so far it hasn't
worked Alistair bunkel Sky News in the
West Bank I don't know